we've got Rob 49 ladies and gentlemen
it's definitely on man it's not playing
my favorite new artist man you've been
doing your thing for the last few years
so Lou glad to finally have you here and
I always wanted to come in you always
tell I was just telling you uh your
music is like uh it gives me hyped bruh
yeah you got records that like if I
played football I'd be willing to crack
a [__] to your records you know
what I'm saying yeah it was definitely
yeah
first of all how long have you been
doing this rap [__] for real for real
probably like two years
now
that's it yeah that's it
wouldn't you record your first song
I recorded my first song
won a pandemic hit
really yes
you're pretty good at this man I know I
don't know how I got that good bro I'll
be looking at myself like that I don't
know how I got that good I swear to God
so how do you go from just starting the
rap to just kind of catching on fire so
fast like what what was the moment or
the song or the particular meeting or
what was it that kind of changed
everything for you
um probably in my city like I ain't
gonna lie like in my city I've been
hiding my citizens on first job like so
it it was already that I think vulture
Island was the one that really liked of
course not matter of fact it wasn't it
was Hustler okay hustling that's the
song that really did it maybe like oh
this [__] hard night and it's crazy to
think that like with all of the history
in New Orleans when it comes to Hip Hop
I feel like in Louisiana Baton Rouge
just they really had a run over the last
decade and I feel like you're kind of
like one of the first like New Orleans
artists in a while that has like really
caught National like nah since Wayne for
real for real for real yeah nobody like
it's crazy too yeah it's like such a uh
New Orleans the greatest it's one of my
favorite places I've ever visited I love
it there
um what area are you from
um downtown okay I have a project design
project
so I went to uh
where do we go eat hot wings no there
was a hot wing place that the dude from
do you remember the group Drew when I
was in UTP
skip he owned a hot wing place what that
is man
a bunch of drinks named after famous
people they had like Obama juice and
Oprah juice well no I ain't gonna lie to
taking the watermelon some of the best
wings in the city bro some of the best
movies I've ever had nah them crazy yeah
you got me one too you know that [__]
was so good damn bro yeah and I remember
just going in there like oh yeah the
dude from UTP was this place I was like
what what's the spots to eat out too
I don't know
honestly bro if I'm gonna be honest out
here like LA's food situation is
probably a little overrated I'm gonna go
to boil Boiling Crab boy
I want the bull I think that's what it's
called where they have the bag of
seafood no not boil boil boa like some
[__] like that oh boa this the
steakhouse yeah yeah I mean it's a
steakhouse but they had a crab they had
a crab that was cut on both sides so all
you gotta do is this to the crab fall
right now well that's the best [__] man
this is so good they used to do a brunch
out here at the Four Seasons I don't
know if they still do it but it's like
150 a person yeah you go in and they
have king crab legs already open for you
cause I love crabs man I need to be the
hardest [__] though is open in the
[__] crab bruh I ain't never used to
like opening crabs I ain't never used to
like even having crabs because I ain't
know how to open them and then you'll
cut yourself open them some pain in the
ass when I learned how to do it though
that's all I want to eat yeah crabs are
amazing I mean [__] y'all be eating all
the [__] crawfish and [__] out there
in New Orleans damn you got me on cuff
isn't that I can't do the Crawfish it's
something about the eyes I can't do it I
can do all the other shellfish in the
world it's crazy bro like that's the
best [__] that [__] better than crab
that [__] and everything really I swear
I've never seen from New Orleans I've
never tried it everywhere else is trash
everywhere in this world trade I had the
um what's y'all type of sandwiches the
po boys I had those from what well you
know what I've been in New Orleans twice
where you went to jeans jeans I don't
even know bro you didn't go to jeans you
didn't really do nothing man they set
jeans down the recipe I went to some
spot um in the French Quarter for sure
nah yeah no you probably went to Acme or
something I don't know I know that there
was like a place with green grenade
drinks oh you went to the hand grenade
please yeah and um that was the first
time I had ever seen a car on like
32-inch rims
[Applause]
oh yeah I seen a couple dudes do that
like I just seen one dude do that man I
got this man cut the we hit every bump
we hit it felt like we hit a speed boat
right because like there's no way that's
just not practical I can't yes if
something else was like there's dunks
and then there's whatever that is that's
something else uh